لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم لنا من الامم
المتحده في نيويوركا السفير افريد خوجا
مندوب البانيا في مجلس الامن الدولي وهي
من الدول التي دعت الى جانب اوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده الى عقد جلسه هذا اليوم
كيف صارت هذه الجلسه وما هو المؤمل منها
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه هذه الجلسه
حول الموضوع متعلق باوكرانيا رغم انه كان
ضمن القرارات والاعلانات التي قامت بها
روسيا من اجل نقل اسلحه نوويه الى بلد اخر
الى بيلاروسيا كان كانت كنز الجلسات
الاخرى فما سمعناه كان مجرد تبريرات لهذه
التحرك الذي قامت به روسيا هو الذي
وكان ايضا
كالعاده التبريرات واعذار لحربها في
اوكرانيا
ولتبرير هذه هذا التصرف الذي لا سابق له
اول عمليه تجري بعد اتفاقيه حظر انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه من بلد الى اخر وبالتالي
اعتقد ان مناقشات كانت جيده فقد كان هناك
بطريقه مفهومه تعبير كثير عن القلق شديد
عبرت عنه كثير من الدولة ليس من الدول
الغربيه فقط
كان افضل طريقه
لتطبيق
محافظه معاهده حضره شارع السحريه هي ليس
يكون زياده عدد الاطراف المعنيه وزياده
طرق توصيل كما يحاولون يفعلون في
بيلاروسيا وبالتالي كان هذا هو الجو الذي
الساده المجلس فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع
ما هو واضح تماما هذا التصرف
يتوافق مع السياسه التي تقودها روسيا منذ
اكثر من سنه
وذلك بانتهاك ميثاق الامم المتحده وانتهاك
القانون الدولي وبانتهاك الكثير من
القرارات مجلس الامن ونعتقد ان هذا التحرك
بالاخير هو مجرد استفزاز اخر مع الاستفادي
الى تصعيد الوضع الذي بالاصل المتوتر
المقصود يعني عقدت هذه الجلسه بسبب تصعيد
روسيا بالحديث عن النووي ام بسبب نشر
صواريخ تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا وهي تقول
بانها دوله صديقه بالنسبه لها
ان العذار التي سمعناها هي كما حصل في
السابق رغم انه لابد من القول
حصلت قبل المعاهده وهي متوافقه مع الاسلحه
النوويه لكن ما واجهها اهليا هو ان روسيا
تقوم بهجوم قاسيه على بلد اخر وتقوم
بالنقل الاسلحه الى بلد يمكن ان يستخدم
كقاعده لهجوم على بلدان الاخرى او بلد اخر
هو اوكرانيا وبالتالي ايضا علينا ننظر
الامر ايضا في سياق التطورات الداخليه
داخل روسيا
وتطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا ولابد نشاهد
هذا النبره
النوويه بدات تزداد في روسيا وفي كل امراه
تصدير مشاكل على الارض وعندما تجلس نفسها
في موقف صعب
وهناك لحظات نجاح في
نفردتها وعدوانها في اوكرانيا يكون بحاجه
الى المزيد من الكلام القاسي والخشن
الراي العام لديها هذا ما نشهده في هذه
التصرف روسيا تريد اخافه الاوروبيين
والراي العام الاوروبي وتريد ايضا زياده
المخاطر في هذه الحرب وهذه وهذا التصرف هو
يقع في ضمن السياسه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
يعني روسيا كما نعرف بانها عضو في دائم في
مجلس الامن ولها حق الفيتو وبالتالي ما
الهدف من هذه الجلسه هل الهدف مثلا الضغط
على روسيا طبعا لن يكون هناك ادانا لانها
تستطيع
استخدام الفيتو
نحن لا نبقى صامطين لا يبقى فقط نتفرج على
الوضع ونرى ما تقوم به روسيا ولكن نبقى
صامتين ونحن نشاهد ان ميثاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي وحتى بنيت الامن الامن
العالمي في خطر
كما بطريقه شاهدناها بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبالتالي الغرض من هذه الجلسه هي
من جديد وعزل روسيا وايضا لمواجهه اي خطاب
تقدمه روسيا وهذا ما نقوم في كل مره نجتمع
حول الموضوع مع الاسف لا نستطيع
المزيد من الاجراءات في مجلس الامن نظرا
لعضويه كما قلتم عضويه روسيا في الدائمه
في المجلس الثامن لكن لابد ان نقول بشكل
واضح بصوت مرتفع بان ان الهدف من مجلس
الامن هو نجع عالم اكثر سلاما وان يحمي
المدنيين وان يعمل من اجل تحقيق الامن
والسلام وليس نشر الاسلحه النوويه وليس
مهاجمه المدنيين وتدمير دول اخرى الهدف من
هذا الاجتماع ايضا التواصل مع الجمهور راي
عام عام واسع وهذا سعيد فرصه وخاطب جماهير
واللي يعرفوا الناس من يقوم بماذا ومن
المسؤول ومن في يوم يجب
محاسبته على ما يحصل حاليا في اوكرانيا
اليوم اعلنت روسيا عن
الخطه او العقيده السياسيه المحدثه خاصه
اتجاهات والغربيه هل تقلقكم هذه العقيده
هل ترون فيها شيئا جديدا
عقيده جديده
روسيا حاليا فبالتالي بل ان الغرب هو خطر
الاكبر لا يعتقد ان روسيا تعمل نحو السلام
ولا تعمل نحو المستقبل التي ترى فيه نفسه
جزء من البنيه البنيه الامن الاوروبي بشكل
عام نحن
ندين هذه الوثيقه سندوسها بشكل كامل
ونتحدث عن تاثيراتها على الامن الاوروبيه
وعلى منطقتنا نحن في منطقه البلطيق والاخذ
ان هذا تسير في الطريقه الصحيح ولا اعتقد
ان هذه الوثيقه تجعل قارتنا اكثر امنا ذلك
سيساعد حتى روسيا نفسها في سياسته
الخارجيه
مندوبه البانيا في مجلس الامن الدولي
المتحدثا من نيويورك شكرا لك